DEMOCRATS START TO FEAR AND MAKE
IT YOUR BACKLASH.
AND WHETHER TRUMP CAN GET
MUELLER TO WIND UP HIS
INVESTIGATION BY CONSENTING TO
AN INTERVIEW.
LET'S LOOK AT SPYGATE.
THAT'S WHAT PRESIDENT TRUMP
CALLS A GROWING REPORTS THAT THE
FBI UNDER OBAMA PLACED AT LEAST
ONE INFORMANT OR SPY IN HIS
PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN.
THOSE REPORTS ALSO FUELED
SUSPICION ON THE RIGHT THAT THE
RUSSIAN INVESTIGATION HAS BEEN
NOTHING MORE THAN A POLITICAL
COUP BY OBAMA ALLIES IN THE DEEP
STATE AGAINST THE DULY ELECTED
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
IN AN ERA OF THE EXPLODING
SURVEILLANCE STATE.
HAVE WE ACTUALLY WITNESSED AN
INFILTRATION OF THE PRESIDENTIAL
CAMPAIGN OF THE OPPOSING PARTY?
IN AN EDITORIAL IN WEDNESDAY'S
INVESTOR'S DAILY POINTS OUT HOW
TIMING IS EVERYTHING.
THEY POINTED OUT THAT THE TIMING
OF THE RUSSIAN INVESTIGATION
KEEP SHIFTING, AND THE EARLIER
THE PROBE BEGAN "THE LESS LIKELY
IT IS TO HAVE ANYTHING TO DO
WITH RUSSIAN INVOLVEMENT IN THE
2016 ELECTIONS BUT EVERYTHING TO
DO WITH STOPPING THE SURPRISING
SURGE OF TRUMP DURING THE G.O.P.
PROBABLY PRIMARIES AND BEYOND."
LET'S EXAMINE THAT PROSPECT WITH
SOME TOP-NOTCH EXPERTS.
FORMER FBI AGENT JEFF BEATTY IS
IN ORLANDO.
IN WASHINGTON, BILL BENNY WHO
SERVED MORE THAN 30 YEARS AS TOP
INTEL OFFICIAL WITH THE NSA
BEFORE TURNING WHISTLE-BLOWER.
AND HERE IN NEW YORK, STEVE
ROGERS, FORMER FBI JOINT
TERRORISM TASK FORCE.
STEVE, LET'S START WITH YOU.
I HAVE A THEORY HERE, ONE IS BAD
AND ONE'S A LITTLE WORSE.
FIRST, THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION
THOUGHT THERE WAS RUSSIA
INFILTRATION SO THEY USE THE
TRUMP OFFICIALS AS BAIT IN ORDER
TO LURE THE RUSSIANS IN.
BUT NOTHING MATERIALIZED, AND
THEY LOOKED AROUND AND THOUGHT,
I HAVE SOME TRUMP PEOPLE ON THE
HOOK HERE, LET'S TURN THE
CRUISE.
AND SCREWS.
OR, IT WAS DECEITFUL FROM THE
VERY BEGINNING AND THEY WANTED
EYES AND EARS ON THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN.
SO WITHOUT ANY PROBABLE CAUSE,
THEY COOKED UP THIS ECHO CHAMBER
OF SPIES AND LIES AND
MISINFORMATION TO GET THE
SURVEILLANCE.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> IF THEY WERE GOING FOR THE
RUSSIANS, THEY WOULD HAVE GONE
FOR THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
THEY ARE IN THEIR HANDS ARE THE
GREATEST ASSETS OF HUMAN
INTELLIGENCE RIGHT IN THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN.
THEY WOULD HAVE WIRED THOSE
INDIVIDUALS UP AND SAID THE
RUSSIANS ARE COMING AFTER YOU,
WE NEED YOU AND WE NEED YOU TO
WIRE YOU UP.
THEY ARE GOING AFTER
DONALD TRUMP.
>> Jesse: BILL, WHERE ARE THE
RUSSIANS HERE IN THIS
INVESTIGATION?
WE SEE LOTS OF SPIES AND FBI
PEOPLE BUT WE HAVEN'T SEEN A LOT
OF RUSSIAN SPIES.
HAVE THEY EVER MATERIALIZED?
>> EVEN THE EFFORT THEY PUT
FORTH TO SAY IT WAS A RUSSIAN
HACKER TURNED OUT TO BE A VERY
CLEAR FABRICATION.
IT'S PROVABLE THROUGH FORENSICS,
THAT IT'S NOT A VALID DOWNLOAD
IT REMOTELY.
SO ALL OF IT WAS FABRICATED.
>> Jesse: SO JEFF, LIKE BILL
JUST MENTIONED, IT ALL STARTED
WITH THE SO-CALLED HACK OF THE
DEMOCRAT COMPUTERS.
NOW THE COUNTER INTEL
INVESTIGATION OPENED UP A COUPLE
WEEKS AFTER THE EMAILS RELEASED
IN THE SUMMER WITH DEBBIE
WASSERMAN SCHULTZ.
AND REMEMBER THEY RAKE THE
PRIMARIES, ALL THAT STUFF.
WHY DIDN'T THE FBI THEN GO LOOK
AT THE SERVER AT THE DNC AND DO
A FORENSIC AUDIT?
WOULDN'T THAT BE THE FIRST PLACE
YOU WOULD LOOK IF YOU ARE
LOOKING FOR RUSSIAN INFILTRATION
LOOKING FOR RUSSIAN INFILTRATIO
INFILTRATION?
>> WELL THAT GOES BACK TO 2015.
I'M A BELIEVER IN YOUR COURSE OF
ACTION, TOO, THAT YOU OUTLINED
AT THE TOP OF THE SHOW.
BUT LET ME GIVE YOU WHAT I SEE
AS THE BLUFF, THE BOTTOM LINE UP
FRONT.
THE FBI GAVE A DEFENSIVE
BRIEFING TO THE DEMOCRATIC
NATIONAL COMMITTEE WHEN THEY HAD
INFORMATION THAT THERE WAS A
FOREIGN ENTITY TRYING TO SWAY,
INFLUENCE, MOVE INTO OR
PENETRATE THE DEMOCRATIC
APPARATUS.
THEY DID NOT DO THAT FOR THE
REPUBLICAN APPARATUS, AS STEVE
ALLUDED TO.
BUT THEY DID FROM THE VERY
BEGINNING WAS TREAT THE
REPUBLICAN APPARATUS
DIFFERENTLY.
DEMOCRAT, DEFENSIVE BRIEFING,
LET'S WORK TOGETHER.
A REPUBLICAN.
I THINK IT WAS NOTHING MORE THAN
A FIG LEAF TO USE OTHER
GOVERNMENT AGENCIES TO INTRODUCE
A RUSSIAN REASON AS TO WHY THEY
COULD GO AHEAD AND LAUNCH AN
INVESTIGATION, FOR TWO PURPOSES.
FIRST OF ALL, TO GET POLITICAL
INTELLIGENCE AS TO WHAT WAS
GOING ON ON THE INSIDE OF THE
CAMPAIGN SO THEY COULD USE IT,
AND SECONDLY, TO BE ABLE TO
DESTROY THEIR ENEMY.
THESE GUYS, NOT TO USE A CHRIS
MATTHEWS REFERENCE, BUT THESE
GUYS WERE PLAYING HARDBALL.
>> Jesse: THERE ARE NO CHRIS
MATTHEWS OF REFERENCES ON THIS
SHOW, THOSE ARE NOW BAND FOR THE
REST OF THE HOUR.
>> NO MORE [LAUGHS]
>> Jesse: IT BUT YOU DID TOUCH
ON A SERIOUS ISSUE, THEY DID
HAVE SUSPICIONS ABOUT EITHER
PAIGE OR MANNA FORT OR
PAPADOPOULOS IN THE SPRING.
AND INSTEAD OF INTERVIEWING
WHOEVER, THEY DON'T DO ANY OF
THAT.
THEY DON'T EVEN ALERT
DONALD TRUMP THAT, WE ARE
SUPPOSED TO PROTECT YOU, THERE
COULD BE SOME ISSUES.
INSTEAD THEY JUST WIRETAP
EVERYBODY AND SEND SPY RINGS
THROUGHOUT THE WHOLE CAMPAIGN.
IT DOESN'T SEEM LIKE AN
ANTI-RUSH OPERATION, IT SEEMS
LIKE AN ANTI-TRUMP OPERATION.
>> IF THEY DIDN'T EVEN GO INTO
THE DNC TO SEE IF THERE WAS A
RUSSIAN OPENING THE BACK DOOR TO
THE SERVERS.
>> I BELIEVE THE STATE SAID THAT
JAY JAMES COMEY TESTIFIED BEFORE
CONGRESS AND GIVE
HILLARY CLINTON A PASS, THEY
NEVER REALLY PURSUED THE 33,000
MISSING EMAILS, NUMBER ONE.
WHAT HAPPENED TO BILL CLINTON
AND THE FAMOUS TARMAC MEETING AT
THE AIRPORT WITH LORETTA LYNCH?
THEY GAVE HER A PASS.
AND AS I SAID EARLIER, WHY
DIDN'T THEY GO TO THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN AND SAY, I THINK THE
RUSSIANS ARE COMING.
WHAT WE NEED YOU TO DO IS WIRE
YOUR PEOPLE UP, WE WANT TO TRAP
YOUR PEOPLE.
>> THEFT BECAUSE THEY HAD THEM
ALL WIRED, ONCE YOU GET ONE
PERSON IN THE CAMPAIGN YOU HAVE
THE WHOLE CAMPAIGN.
>> Jesse: AND HALF OF THESE
GUYS WERE COMING IN AND OUT OF
TRUMP TOWER.
THE OTHER COUPLE GUYS WERE
OVERSEAS.
THEY THREW EVERYTHING AT THIS
CAMPAIGN.
THEY THREW SPIES, INFORMANTS,
SECRET SUBPOENAS, ELECTRONIC
SURVEILLANCE, FAKE DOSSIERS,
UNMASKING.
EVERY TECHNICALITY THAT YOU HAVE
USED IN AN INVESTIGATION, THEY
THREW EVERYTHING AT THESE GUYS.
AND YOU KNOW WHAT?
DONALD TRUMP STILL WON THE
ELECTION, WHAT DOES THAT SAY?
>> NO EVIDENCE OF COLLUSION.
>> KEEP IN MIND, JESSE, THEY ARE
USING THE NSA DATABASES, AND
THEY CAN RETROACTIVELY ANALYZE
ALL THE DATA ON EVERYONE IN THE
CAMPAIGN.
>> Jesse: NOW CLAPPER, AS WE
ALL REMEMBER, ONE OF THE TOP
INTELLIGENCE CHIEFS UNDER
PRESIDENT BARACK OBAMA HAS BEEN
DOING THE ROUNDS ON TELEVISION,
AND HE THE WHOLE SPYING THING,
KIND OF.
>> I THINK HE IS DELIBERATELY
SPENDING A NARRATIVE, WHEREBY HE
IS THE VICTIM OF THE DEEP STATE
SPYING ON HIM OR SPYING ON A
CAMPAIGN, WHICH IS NOT THE CASE.
THAT'S WHAT I WOULD CALL MY
INFORMED OPINION, THAT GIVEN THE
MASSIVE EFFORT THAT THE RUSSIANS
MADE IN THE NUMBER OF CITIZENS
THAT THEY TOUCHED, TO ME, IT
EXCEEDS LOGIC AND CREDULITY THAT
THEY DIDN'T AFFECT THE ELECTION.
AND IT'S MY BELIEF THEY ACTUALLY
TURNED IT.
>> SO I ASK YOU, WAS THE FBI
SPYING ON TRUMP'S CAMPAIGN?
>> KNOW THEY WERE NOT.
THEY WERE SPYING -- A TERM I
DON'T PARTICULARLY LIKE BUT,
WHAT THE RUSSIANS WERE DOING.
>> WHY ISN'T HE HAPPY ABOUT
THAT?
>> HE SHOULD BE.
>> Jesse: FIRST OF ALL,
JAMES CLAPPER IS ON THE VIEW.
I DON'T THINK THE TOP INTEL GUY
FOR ANY TEAM SHOULD BE ON THE
VIEW.
SECOND OF ALL, HE JUST ADMITTED
THEY SPIED BUT THEY WERE TRYING
TO HELP PRESIDENT TRUMP.
PRESIDENT TRUMP SHOULD THANK
THEM FOR SPYING ON THE CAMPAIGN,
RIGHT?
>> JESSE, ONE THING YOU SAID
OPENING UP AND THE QUESTION IS,
DID THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION
KNOW ABOUT THIS, I DON'T BELIEVE
FOR ONE MINUTE THEY DIDN'T KNOW.
I BELIEVE OBAMA KNEW WHAT WAS
GOING ON AND HIS JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT KNEW WHAT WAS GOING
ON, AND IT'S ALL FALLING APART.
>> Jesse: THAT'S A GREAT
POINT, BILL.
WE HAVE EVIDENCE THAT THE
WHITE HOUSE WAS IN THE LOOP ON
THIS.
WE HAVE SOME TEXT THAT AT
ONE POINT SAY, THE WHITE HOUSE
IS RUNNING THIS, TALKING ABOUT
THIS COUNTERINTELLIGENCE
OPERATION.
THERE ARE BRIEFINGS WITH THE TOP
PEOPLE IN THE OBAMA TEAM, THE
IN ON THE LOOP, HOW COULD OBAMA
NOT KNOW THAT THIS WAS
HAPPENING?
>> AFTER ALL, JUST TAKE THE
STEEL DOSSIER.
THAT WAS SOME FELLOW FROM AM I
SIX, WHICH IS THE EQUIVALENT OF
CIA.
THE END CIA WAS INVOLVED, THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
THE ONLY PLACE THAT THOSE
ORGANIZATIONS COME TO A POINT
WHERE IT CAN BE ORDERED AND
COORDINATED IS THE PRESIDENT.
>> Jesse: AND WE DO HAVE
RECORDS OF THIS SPY, OR WHATEVER
YOU WANT TO CALL HIM IN ENGLAND
WAS GETTING PAID PRETTY
HANDSOMELY BY THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION, RIGHT AROUND THE
SAME TIME HE WAS RUNNING THESE
DIRTY TRICKS.
THIS GUY WAS CONNECTED TO AM I
SIX AND CIA.
HE HAD DONE SOME DIRTY TRICKS ON
ELECTIONS IN THE PAST.
HE'S BEEN OUTSPOKEN ABOUT HIS
SUPPORT FOR HILLARY CLINTON AND
EVEN TRIED TO GET A JOB WITHIN
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
AFTERWARDS.
SO JEFF, IT'S ALL COMING APART.
>> IT IS.
TO SEE KLAPPER AND BRENNAN OUT
THERE WITH THE TITLES OF FORMER
DIRECTOR, ET CETERA, THESE GUYS
ARE NO LONGER INTELLIGENCE
OFFICIALS, AND IT'S TIME FOR THE
PRESIDENT TO START STRIKING BACK
AT THEM.
AND BY THAT, I MEAN, A LOT OF
THESE SENIOR PEOPLE GET TO KEEP
THEIR SECURITY CLEARANCES SO
THEY CAN CONSULT WITHIN PEOPLE
IN GOVERNMENT.
THERE IS NO NEED TO HAVE
SECURITY CLEARANCES ANYMORE.
START TAKING AWAY BRENNAN'S
SECURITY CLEARANCE, OR ACCESS TO
ANYTHING, KLAPPER SECURITY
CLEARANCE OR ACCESS TO ANYTHING,
BECAUSE THEY HAVE BECOME
PARTISANS.
THEY ARE NOT OUT THERE DOING
WHAT THEY SHOULD BE AS
PROFESSIONALS WHICH IS TO DO
THEIR JOB AND BE BLIND,
AGNOSTIC, WHEN IT COMES TO PARTY
POLITICS.
>> Jesse: THAT IS A BOLD MOVE
TO MAKE AND I THINK
PRESIDENT TRUMP WOULD MAKE THAT
MOVE OR FLIRT WITH DOING THAT.
YOU BROUGHT UP AN INTERESTING
POINT ABOUT PEOPLE, THOUGH,
STILL IN THE FBI OR IN THE DOJ
THAT DO HAVE THESE CLEARANCES.
WE ARE HEARING WORD HERE AT
FOX NEWS THAT THERE MAY BE SOME
PEOPLE COMING FORWARD, MAY BE
SOME WHISTLE-BLOWERS THAT MIGHT
LIKE TO TALK ABOUT HOW JAMES
COMEY RAN THESE OPERATIONS, HOW
HE DEALT WITH THE CLINTONS AND
HOW HE DEALT WITH THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN.
IF YOU GUYS WERE STILL IN THE
GOVERNMENT, WOULD YOU GUYS COME
FORWARD AND TESTIFY AND LAWYER
UP?
>> THE GOOD NEWS, THE OIG REPORT
IS ABOUT TO COME OUT AND THE OIG
HAS THE ABILITY TO PROTECT THE
WHISTLE-BLOWERS WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE AND WITHIN
THE FBI.
SO HOPEFUL AND OPTIMISTIC THAT
SOME OF THOSE FOLKS WILL DO THE
RIGHT THING AND GET PROTECTED BY
THE OIG, AND WE MIGHT SEE SOME
OF THEIR CONTENT COMING OUT IN
HIS REPORT.
>> JESSE, THEY NEED TO BREAK
DOWN THE BLUE WALL OF SILENCE.
WHEN THE SHIP IS SINKING, NO ONE
WILL THROW YOU A LIFE RAFT.
>> ACCORDING TO THE
CONSTITUTION, YOU HAVE RECOURSE
TO CONGRESS.
AND THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT I DID IN
2002, AND I WON.
I WENT TO CONGRESS TO REPORT
SOME OF THE SPYING ON U.S.
CITIZENS.
IT'S ALL A LIE WHEN THEY TELL
YOU THEY ARE AFTER THE RUSSIANS.
THEIR TAPPING POINTS IN THE
FAIRVIEW PROGRAM ARE INTERNAL IN
THE U.S.
THERE ARE 11 POINTS THAT THEY
COULD PICK UP EVERY FOREIGNER
INTO OR OUT OF OR THROUGH THE
UNITED STATES, IF THEY STAY AT
THOSE 11 POINTS, THEY GET THEM
ALL.
>> Jesse: THE RUSSIANS THAT